Kamali thank you hello and welcome to
the Daily climate show coming up British
households and businesses are warned
that the energy crisis could result in
blackouts this winter
how this Summer's droughts were made 20
times more likely by global warming
[Music]
and President Biden visits the site of
the latest natural disaster to hit the
US declaring there's no way that climate
change can be denied
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now National Grid has warned that in a
worst case scenario households and
businesses could experience planned
three-hour power Cuts this winter if gas
supplies run very low well to try to
avoid too much power being used at peak
times and incentive scheme is being put
into place to help ease the risk of the
lights going out so customers can sign
up with their electricity supplier and
get money back on their bills if they
shift their use of power away from times
of high demand to help prevent blackouts
and larger businesses will be paid for
reducing Demand by shifting their times
of energy use or switching to batteries
or generators in peak times
the scheme will run between November and
March and it's likely to operate on at
least 12 separate occasions more if
needed to protect supplies and there's
also a warning that electricity could be
cut off to households and businesses for
three hour blocks from January if
there's not enough power to keep
stations going though to tackle a loss
of imports from the continent two
gigawatts of coal-fired power plants
will be on standby
well our climate change and energy
correspondent hanus Thomas Peter has
more detail of what's been announced
the National Grid's winter Outlook is in
the very worst case scenario
anticipating a crisis and so in order to
prevent us from getting to that
situation it is launching the framework
of a scheme that will allow consumers
and businesses to sign up to a voluntary
scheme via their electricity suppliers
to be paid when they use electricity
away from peak time so that's charging
electric vehicles overnight charging
washing machines during the day avoiding
those Peak consumption periods during
the morning and evening because it is
warning that in a very worst case
scenario without that scheme in place
with a very cold period of weather with
issues importing electricity from from
Norway and others and potentially with a
gas shortage from European counter
counterparts and elsewhere there could
be periods of time when there are
planned blackouts for UK households
potentially for up to three hour blocks
at a time now this will be a real blow
for Liz truss who has been very
reluctant to talk about individual
Behavior change and reduction in
consumption and has promised there will
be no rationing well it's obvious that
the National Grid thinks differently and
campaigners are really saying look the
reason why even in this situation or
we're having to worry about this worst
case scenario is because we have failed
to invest adequately in the previous
decade or so in renewable energy in this
country in wind and solar power and in
energy efficiencies like home insulation
schemes and so on and had we done that
we wouldn't be reliant on fossil fuels
in the same way at all we will be
insulated from geopolitical events and
we wouldn't have to be thinking about
how to keep the lights on
well with the emphasis on the amount of
gas that will be available to fire power
stations let's take a look at our data
dashboard shall we and see just how much
of our energy Supply is being produced
by gas right now and you can see that
figure is 18.1 percent at the moment and
there's the figure for Renewables around
66 coming from Renewables at the moment
now as households across the UK worry
about affording their heating over this
winter Edinburgh council is to improve
the Energy Efficiency of more than a
thousand homes in the coming year after
receiving 5 million pounds of Scottish
Government funding the funding is to
specifically target areas of fuel
poverty and will provide wall insulation
to reduce heat loss from homes as well
as renewable Technologies such as solar
panels and battery storage
now the UN climate Summit cop 27 begins
one month from today in the Egyptian Red
Sea Resort of charmel Sheikh and at a
conference in the run-up to that Summit
the head of the Egyptian delegation has
attacked wealthy Nations for failing to
honor a climate Finance pledge
13 years ago at cop15 in Copenhagen the
Richer countries agreed to provide a
hundred billion dollars a year to
developing countries by 2020 and that's
a pledge that still hasn't been met
now a new study has found that the
drought that much of the northern
hemisphere suffered this summer was made
20 times more likely by climate change
that's already taken place now the study
concluded that a drought like this
Summers would have struck around once
every 400 years had the world not heated
up
but since human activity has increased
the global temperatures by around 1.2
degrees Celsius such a drought can now
be expected every 20 years
now the study also found that an
additional 24 000 people died across
Europe in part because of this Summer's
Heat
well let's get more on this from our
climate reporter Victoria Seabrook and
Victoria I guess the implication of this
is that we all have to expect more
droughts in the future now
yes exactly and that's really key is
just how widespread this was so we heard
that this is for the whole of the
northern hemisphere apart from the
tropical region where drought was 20
times more likely so we heard a lot
about drought in the UK two-thirds of EU
land was in drought at one point half of
the U.S big parts of China so this is
huge parts of the world all together and
what scientists are saying is that
whereas before we may have seen isolated
extreme events like the summer of the
hot summer of 1974. now what we're
seeing is multiple simultaneous extreme
events and this happening all at the
same time can only be explained by
climate change they say now let's just
remind ourselves of some of the impacts
of this it hit um it hit energy
production so places like Italy and
Portugal struggle to produce as much
hydropower as usual because there was
less water EDF struggled to cool down
one of its nuclear reactors just as the
EU was struggling with limited energy
supplies anyway likewise it it hit crop
yields just as we were grappling with um
food security problems because of what
was happening in Ukraine so this is an
example of how climate change can
multiply existing threats
Victoria thanks very much indeed
well Turkey Greece and Cyprus are still
experiencing the heat wave which gripped
Europe this summer with soaring
temperatures expected to continue
throughout this month records for the
hottest October day were broken in
Antalya this weekend with temperatures
hitting a high of 41 degrees Celsius the
hottest October day in Turkey since
1930.
well the unusually low water level in
the Lower Mississippi river is causing
barges to get stuck in mud and sand
disrupting River travel for shippers
boaters and even passengers on a cruise
line lack of rainfall in recent weeks
has left the Mississippi River
approaching record low levels in some
areas from Missouri South through
Louisiana the U.S Coast Guards had at
least eight groundings of barges have
been reported just in the past week
when staying with the U.S President
Biden has visited parts of Florida that
were devastated by Hurricane Ian last
week speaking in Fort Myers Mr Biden
said that the series of natural
disasters to have hit the U.S recently
means that climate change can no longer
be denied
unfortunately I've been to a lot of
disaster areas in the last couple months
last six months you know more uh more
fires have burned in the west and the
Southwest burned everything right to the
ground then in the entire state of New
Jersey the as much room as that takes up
and the reservoirs out west are are down
to almost zero we're in a situation
where the Colorado River looks more like
a stream there's a lot going on and I
think the one thing this has finally
ended is a discussion about whether or
not there's climate change we should do
something about it
well NBC correspondent Shaquille
Brewster was in Fort Myers when
President Biden visited
President Biden announced the opening of
additional disaster recovery centers in
this Fort Myers area and I've been at
one of them the first one to open just
yesterday here in Fort Myers talking to
people and it's really a fascinating
site that you see here we saw hours long
lines people waiting for more than an
hour to speak to a FEMA representative
many of them saying they didn't know
exactly what they were going to say or
what they needed from them but they
wanted some of those basic questions
answered questions like how did they
file a claim how long will that process
take maybe telling me one of the first
steps you need to do after a recovery
after you lost your business after you
lost the items in your home is file that
insurance claim if you have insurance so
this is a site where you also have many
private insurers here with their mobile
response units so if this is intended to
be a One-Stop shop for people in this
area talking with folks here as they
were waiting in line it was clear that
the need here in Fort Myers are really
in this entire area is so large one of
the questions that I asked them after
understanding their specific situation
is what would they want the the
president to know what would they want
the president to see on his trip I want
you to listen to some of those
conversations
uh just basically everybody needs help
and you know that it's not one person or
the other person it's everybody here
we're all uh you know Citizens United
States and you know you always see it on
TV all these places you know destroyed
and gone you always think those poor
people now all of a sudden it's US
President Biden's coming today do you
think he understands the tears that he's
seeing right now
well if he doesn't shed a fear or heal
himself I'd be surprised you know I mean
it's it's just unbelievable
and in this area there are signs of
progress we know that power has been
restored to the vast majority of people
the governor earlier today announcing
that Pine Island which has been closed
off since hurricane Ian made landfall
um that temporary Bridge has now been
built well ahead of schedule so you're
seeing signs of progress in this area
but when you're talking to folks and
when you're looking at the devastation
still so visible it is clear that
there's a long recovery ahead from so
many people back to you
well that's all for today thanks for
watching